Hi I'm Jack, I'm from the great city of Norwich in the UK that I'm actually talking from the middle of Tokyo in the early hours.
大家好，我是杰克，我来自英国伟大的城市诺维奇，但我其实是在清晨的东京市中心和大家说话。
What how I make a mother means to me?
“老爸老妈罗曼史”对我意味着什么？
It's the emphasis on hindsight, the benefit of hindsight and the fact that as bleak and as negative as things may seem in the moment, actually it may be building to something better.
那就是对后见之明的强调，事后诸葛亮的好处，以及这样一个事实：无论当下看起来多么惨淡、多么消极，实际上它可能在为更好的事情做铺垫。
made me set me new on a course in your life, which ultimately leads something better.
让我踏上了生活中的新旅程，最终通向更好的事物。
That means a lot, simply because I, about eight months ago, I had a nervous breakdown.
这意义重大，仅仅因为我，大约八个月前，我精神崩溃了。
I wasn't very happy with my life.
我对自己的生活很不满意。
And here I am eight months now, I'm from that now, and I'm much happier where I am.
而现在八个月过去了，我走出了那段阴影，我对现在的状态满意多了。
I'm in Tokyo for the first time, and I might be in a position to tell the girl that I love that I love her.
我生平第一次来到东京，我或许有机会对我爱的女孩表白。
so and actually seriously thank you for that it's really helped thinking about it and watching the program I don't think you can be emphasised just how much it means to people and how much it means to me I don't know how to thank you for that except for this message Well, hello there, I'm Josh Ratner, I am joined by my friend Craig Thomas for another episode of How We Made Your Mother, Hi Craig.
所以，真的很感谢你，这真的很有帮助，通过思考和观看节目，怎么强调它对人们的意义以及对我个人的意义都不为过，我不知道该怎么感谢你，除了发这条信息。嗨，大家好，我是乔什·拉德纳，我的朋友克雷格·托马斯也加入了我的节目，带来又一期《老爸老妈罗曼史》，嗨，克雷格。
Hey Josh.
嗨，乔什。
Hey.
嗨。
Boy.
天哪。
I don't, maybe one of these openings won't, well, I won't get choked up as it's happening, but I'm 0 for 12 or whatever it is, and not getting choked up.
我不知道，也许有一次开场我不会在事情发生时哽咽，但我现在是12次全有去无回，每次都还是会哽咽。
It's always an amazing way to start the show because this is our first time hearing them.
以这种方式开始节目总是令人惊叹，因为这是我们第一次听到这些留言。
So it kind of puts you on your back foot in a good way, right?
所以这有点让你措手不及，但却是种美妙的体验，对吧？
like, I don't come on knowing what we're going to hear, how I'm going to respond to it.
就像，我来的时候并不知道我们会听到什么，我会有什么反应。
What Jack was saying so, so beautifully.
杰克刚才说得真是太美妙了。
And I think the thing about, I think the medicine, if you could distill what, how I met your mother, the special medicine that it has within it, that people keep going back to it as if it's some kind of like, well, or altar, some sort of like nourishing, life-giving thing, is It doesn't shy away from the low moments, but it gives you this context for viewing the tough stuff in life that says, no, you know, a lot of times you have to be broken, open, so something else can come in.
而且我认为关于……如果你能提炼出《老爸老妈罗曼史》所蕴含的特殊药方，那种让人们不断回头重温，仿佛它是某种源泉、某种圣坛，某种充满滋养、给予生命的事物的力量，那就是它并不回避低谷，但它为你提供了一个看待生活中艰难时刻的视角，告诉你，不，你知道吗，很多时候你必须先碎裂、敞开，好让别的东西进来。
And the old parts of you have to die and go away and wither before the new thing can regenerate and grow.
你旧的部分必须死去、消散并枯萎，新的事物才能再生和成长。
And you know, I was listening to him and I was like, wow, I need to hear this today.
你知道的，我听着他的话，心想，哇，我今天真需要听到这些。
Like, I'm glad you said that, you know?
就像，很高兴你这么说了，你知道吗？
Me too.
我也是。
And I'm just, as you know, winding down my tour and I have certain songs that I'm so glad I wrote them because I get to sing them all the time and I get to hear them again.
正如你所知，我的巡演正接近尾声，有些歌曲我庆幸自己写了它们，因为我可以一直唱它们，还能再次听到它们。
I get to hear them anew.
我能以全新的方式听到它们。
And even working on this show with you, Craig and Alec and everyone else is like, it's just refreshing that message within me, you know, and it's so much, it's bigger than how I your mother, but I think how I met your mother did such a good job at creating, spinning a narrative where people could get, you know, literally punched in the face.
甚至和你、克雷格、亚历克以及其他所有人一起制作这部剧，也让我内心深处的信息焕然一新，你知道的，这意义重大，它超越了《老爸老妈罗曼史》本身，但我认为《老爸老妈罗曼史》在创造、编织一个叙事方面做得太棒了，让人们在经历生活重击（字面意义上的当头棒喝）时……
It was all part of some big plan.
这一切都是某个宏大计划的一部分。
I mean, it's really, it's quite magical.
我的意思是，这真的很神奇。
Well, it's interesting.
嗯，这很有趣。
There's this idea of the one, right?
这里有一个关于“真命天子/女”的概念，对吧？
I'm going to hold on to meet the one.
我要坚持下去，直到遇到那个对的人。
And that is a beautiful thing, right?
这是一件美好的事情，对吧？
That aspiration, that romantic idea of meeting the one.
那种对遇到真爱的高贵追求、浪漫想法。
But what I took from Jack's message, and I think it is in the show too, maybe even as much or more built into the structure of the show, is that when you're in a low moment, you should also hold on for future you.
但我从杰克的留言中领悟到，而且我认为这在剧中也有体现，甚至可能更多地构建在剧集的结构中，那就是当你处于低谷时，你也应该为未来的自己坚持下去。
That's who you're doing it for.
那就是你为之奋斗的目标。
You're holding out an enduring for them so they can get through it.
你为了他们而坚持、忍耐，这样他们就能挺过难关。
You can meet them later.
你以后会遇到他们。
You can meet future you and tell the story.
你可以遇见未来的自己并讲述这个故事。
That's who you owe it to.
这是你对未来的承诺。
That's who you're doing it for.
这就是你为之奋斗的动力。
And it's almost like future me is gonna need some resilience.
这就像未来的我将需要一些韧性。
They're gonna need the lessons and strength that I'm gathering now.
他们需要我现在正在收集的教训和力量。
Because it might even be harder in the future.
因为未来可能会更加艰难。
It's like, I need to, I'm in training for my future self.
这就好像，我需要，我正在为未来的自己进行训练。
And presumably maybe your kids, I think there's that kind of like, there's the storyline of parents' sacrifice for their children.
当然也许还有你的孩子们，我认为这其中有一种……父母为孩子牺牲的故事线。
And we sacrifice for our future selves.
而我们为未来的自己牺牲。
Like it's a really, that's quite a lovely idea.
这真的是一个非常美好的想法。
I love that, Craig.
我喜欢这个观点，克雷格。
Yeah, I mean, I really heard that in what Jack said there.
是的，我的意思是，我在杰克刚才的话里深深地听到了这一点。
So, Jack, thank you.
所以，杰克，谢谢你。
Thanks for reminding us of that part of the show we made that maybe we weren't aware of at the time in a way.
谢谢你提醒我们节目中那部分我们当初可能并没有完全意识到的意义。
And also like, how I met your mother is very much about a man in dialogue with himself.
还有就是，《老爸老妈浪漫史》在很大程度上是一个男人与自己的对话。
Yeah, it is that there's a, certainly the older narrator Ted is in dialogue with this younger self, but on some cosmic weird level, present day Ted, My Ted, the Ted I played, is also in dialogue with his older self because he's always thinking about the front porch down the line and what I'm going to be.
对，确实是这样，年长的旁白泰德在和年轻的自己对话，但在某种奇怪的宇宙层面上，当下的泰德，也就是我，我所扮演的泰德，其实也在和年老的自己对话，因为他总是想着未来的前廊，想着自己将来会成为什么样的人。
He's trying to lay the seeds for his life.
他正为自己的人生播下种子。
And he's mistake prone and he draws erroneous conclusions quite a bit, but he ultimately does string it together.
他会犯错，也经常得出错误的结论，但他最终还是把这一切串联了起来。
And I think there's something about the show that's quite forgiving.
我觉得这部剧有一种非常宽容的特质。
There's a mercy at the heart of it that I think people really respond to like it's okay to make mistakes, it's okay to, you know, it's okay to have a breakdown as Jack said.
它的核心有一种仁慈，我觉得观众对此很有共鸣，比如犯错是没关系的，你知道的，像杰克说的，崩溃一下也是没关系的。
And then before, you know, eight months, eight months is not that long to kind of like swing to the other way.
而且你看，八个月前的事，八个月其实并不算太长，就能发生这样的大逆转。
So it's like, it gives people faith.
所以这让人重燃希望。
I mean, what better thing would you hope for from a television show?
我的意思是，你能从一部电视剧里期望更好的东西吗？
Yeah, it's an honor and a privilege to hear that it meant that to Jack and other people, it's amazing.
是的，听说这部剧对杰克和其他人有这样的意义，我深感荣幸和特权，这太棒了。
And that is the aspirational quality of the show.
这也是这部剧所具有的追求和向往的特质。
It seems at first that it's the aspiration of meeting the one, but in a way it's also just surviving and telling, realizing you're becoming the person who's going to tell this story one day, which I loved head for because that's his drive.
起初看起来，这种追求是遇到真爱，但从某种程度上说，它也只是一种生存和倾诉，意识到自己正在成为那个终有一天会讲述这个故事的人，我非常喜欢泰德这一点，因为那是他的动力。
That's really his drive.
那确实是他的动力。
Yeah.
对。
Well, let's downshift into the episode under discussion this week.
好了，让我们把节奏慢下来，进入我们本周要讨论的剧集。
This episode embodies a lot of what we just talked about.
这一集完美体现了我们刚刚谈到的大部分内容。
Yeah, it really does.
对，确实如此。
And this is kind of, we've been talking about this.
而且，我们之前也一直在讨论这个。
This is kind of part one of a really like a two-part episode around this wedding, this episode, the wedding, which is episode 12, is that right, Alec?
这集实际上是关于这场婚礼的上下两集里的第一部分，也就是第12集，对吧，亚历克？
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
对。
And when did this episode air?
那这一集是什么时候播出的？
This episode first aired on January 9th, 2006.
这一集最初于2006年1月9日播出。
Okay.
好的。
Our first one of the new year.
我们新年的第一集。
and then this led into drum roll, please, episode 13.
然后这就顺理成章地引出了万众期待的第13集。
But let's limit our discussion at least for now to the wedding.
但至少现在，我们还是把讨论限制在“婚礼”这一集上。
You wanna give it- It will be hard.
你想把它——这会很难。
I bid you one last night.
我最后看了一遍。
I watched him as an hour and it plays so great as an hour that it will be really hard not to talk about it as well.
我把它当成一整小时来看了，作为一个小时的剧集，它实在太精彩了，所以不把它们连起来讨论会非常难。
I made a huge mistake watching both together, even though I loved it.
虽然我很喜欢，但把这两集连着看让我犯了个大错。
I loved the hour of this, but we'll talk about the first half hour and then we'll get to this.
我很喜欢这一小时的连播，但我们先聊前半小时，然后再聊后面。
Well, do you wanna do our quick summary as best you can of what happens in this episode of the wedding.
好吧，你能尽量简单总结一下《婚礼》这一集里发生了什么吗？
Yeah, I mean, it's exactly what we just talked about.
好，我的意思是，这正好印证了我们刚才的话题。
It's Ted making a plan, coming up with an idea and an aspiration.
这就是泰德在制定计划，想出一个点子，并抱有期待。
He's gonna bring Robin and his embassy.
他打算带罗宾去参加他收到的婚礼邀请。
And that has to be exactly the way he sees it.
而且一切必须按照他想象中的那样发展。
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, it's actually quite like the one of which preceded it in a way where it's like the plan and then watch the plan fall to absolute shit.
对，其实它有点像前面那一集，都是先制定计划，然后看着计划彻底搞砸。
And then maybe something better emerges out of that.
接着也许会有更好的结果从中诞生。
It's a similar structure.
这是一个相似的结构。
But Ted wants, Ted wants to bring, Ted's feelings for Robin have crept back up, right?
但泰德想，泰德想带罗宾去，泰德对罗宾的感觉又悄悄滋生了，对吧？
And we saw it start in pineapple incident.
我们在《菠萝事件》里就看到了这种迹象。
We saw it when they kissed at the end of the limo, we saw some heat there.
我们看到他们在加长轿车结尾接吻时擦出的火花。
We saw those embers are starting to catch a little, let's turn this little smoke coming out of there again.
我们看到那些余烬开始重新燃起，那种若隐若现的烟雾又冒出来了。
And Ted says, I think I have feelings for Robin again.
然后泰德说，我觉得我又对罗宾有感觉了。
And he wants to bring her to this wedding that they're all going to.
他想带她去他们都要去参加的那个婚礼。
And Ted is convinced he did his thing he always does, which is checking plus one out of this aspirational hope that when he got the wedding invitation and he looked ahead a few months, he would have this belief that he would be in love with somebody and bringing that person.
泰德确信自己做了他常做的那件事，也就是勾选了“加一个同伴”，带着这样一种美好的期盼：当他收到婚礼请柬并展望未来几个月时，他坚信自己会爱上某个人并把那个人带去。
And I love how the whole episode kind of becomes this symposium on is Ted the kind of guy who always checks that box out of his feeling that he's a couple guy, or is Barney actually right when Barney says, you didn't check that box.
我特别喜欢整集剧集如何变成了一场关于这样一个问题的研讨会：泰德是那种总是因为觉得自己是个“有伴侣的人”而习惯性勾选那个选项的人呢，还是巴尼说得对——巴尼说你根本没勾选那个选项。
You check that you were going solo because you knew you were going to go there with me and we're going to hook up with bridesmaids and whatever.
你确认自己一个人去，因为你知道你会和我在那里碰面，而且我们要去泡伴娘什么的。
And I love that the whole episode is kind of this like court case essentially about which guy is Ted.
我特别喜欢整集的内容基本上就像是一场庭审，关于哪个家伙才是泰德。
And of course, in the end, we find out that I was just spoilers that Barney is right, Ted did not check that, which I think is really, really interesting that Ted did not check at that one.
当然，到最后我们发现——剧透一下——巴尼是对的，泰德根本没勾选那一项，我觉得泰德在这一点上没勾选真的、真的很耐人寻味。
And it's a weird thing, again, like how memory plays with us and toys with us, you know, like I'm certain I checked that, you know, because I'm the kind of guy, it also is very field of dreams, you know, this idea of like you build it, they will come, right?
这是一种很奇怪的感觉，再次说明了记忆是如何戏弄我们的，你知道的，我确信自己勾选了，你知道的，因为我是那种类型的家伙，而且这也很有《梦幻田园》的感觉，你知道吗，那种“你若建好，他们就会来”的想法，对吧？
Like totally.
简直太对了。
He's a man of, you know, he's really wanting to, he's wanting to, he's wanting to create space for this other person, but something in him is like self-sabotaging.
他是一个……你知道的，他真的很想，他想为另一个人腾出空间，但他的内心深处却有一种自我破坏的倾向。
And it's even mystifying to him, right?
而且连他自己都觉得很费解，对吧？
There's a thing you want to know.
有一件事你很想知道。
You want to know if Ted checked that box or not, and you do get to find the answer in the end of the episode.
你想知道泰德到底有没有勾选那一栏，而在这一集的结尾，你确实找到了答案。
I really likes that.
我真的很喜欢这一点。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·雷德克（Carl Radke）。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast, More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock, and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
你可能在 Bravo 电视台的《夏日合租屋》里认识我，但在我的播客《更多生活》（More Life）中，我把你们最喜欢的真人秀明星从工作中解放出来，带你们进入那些平时听不到的对话中。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
那些深刻的内容、脆弱的内容、让人不自在的内容。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我采访过席亚拉·米勒、德琳达·梅德利、汤姆·施瓦茨、林赛·哈伯德等等许多人。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们探讨成长过程中的恋爱关系、那些一团糟的事情，以及摄像机没拍到时发生的一切。
New episodes of More Life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
每周都有《更多生活》的新节目上线，请在各大播客平台收听，或在 YouTube 上观看。
And now, back to the show.
现在，让我们回到节目中。
You know, this episode is really, really good.
你知道，这一集真的、真的很棒。
And I also, So, Jordana has remarked that to her, the show's getting funnier as she watches it, but I think that's a consequence of, you know, you know, the characters a little bit deeper, and when they respond as their character would respond, there's pleasure in it, right?
而且我也……乔丹娜曾评论说，对她而言，随着观看的深入，这部剧变得越来越搞笑，但我认为这是因为你对角色有了更深一点的了解，当他们做出符合其角色设定的反应时，你会从中获得乐趣，对吧？
Because you're like, oh, that's old so-and-so.
因为你会想：“哦，又是那个老家伙。”
Like, that sounds just like, you know, Marshall loves the cake.
比如，那听上去就像是，你知道的，马歇尔喜欢蛋糕。
Oh, he's a cake lover.
哦，他是个蛋糕爱好者。
You know, like, I actually jumped ahead.
你知道的，其实我刚才跳过了。
And I had some notes that I warned you feel like the ravings of a madman, because I watched this for week ago.
我记了一些笔记，我之前警告过你，它们看起来像是个疯子的胡言乱语，因为我是一周前看这一集的。
Do you remember writing these notes?
你还记得自己写过这些笔记吗？
I don't.
我不记得了。
Do you go on this sort of a fugue state?
你当时是陷入了那种神游状态吗？
I was on so much tantrum.
我当时情绪太崩溃了。
I have no memory.
我完全不记得了。
It was just a tantrum and sandwich weekend.
那纯粹是一个发脾气和吃三明治的周末。
What is Dear Carcasson a hunting trip?
“亲爱的卡卡松去打猎”是什么鬼？
That is.
就是那个。
Okay.
好吧。
This is good.
这很有意思。
We're going to make a little game show out of this one.
我们要用这个玩个小游戏。
I'm going to try to...
我打算试着……
The game is me translating Josh's...
游戏就是我来翻译乔什的……
The game is a fun.
这个游戏真有意思。
I have the answer to this one.
我知道这个的答案。
The answer is, Barney says you do not bring a date to a wedding, because it's like bringing a deer cart to 100 groups, which is the creepiest possible metaphor.
答案是，巴尼说你不能带女伴去参加婚礼，因为这就像带一辆猎鹿车去一百个群聊一样，这是最让人毛骨悚然的比喻。
Barney is clearly a murderer.
巴尼显然是个杀人犯。
Barney has a murder house somewhere.
巴尼在某处有个谋杀屋。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
That's what that one was.
原来那个是这个意思。
And you write that down because you heard it, and at the time you think you were so disturbed by that image that you wanted to ask about it, or you don't even remember.
你把它记下来是因为你听到了，当时你觉得这个画面太让人不安了，所以你想问问关于它的事，或者你根本就不记得了。
You have no recollection of it.
你对它一点印象都没有了。
I remember just being startled by it.
我只记得当时被它吓了一跳。
Like, it's a startling image.
就像，这是一个让人震惊的画面。
It's a startling image.
这是一个让人震惊的画面。
As I think they point out to Barney and the moment too, to be fair.
我觉得他们当时对巴尼也指出了这一点，说句公道话。
I really like, this is another, I'm trying to get in the habit of seeing when I think I did a good job.
我真的很喜欢，这是另一个，我正在努力养成一种习惯，那就是在我自认为表现得不错的时候指出来。
It's a self-esteem builder, right?
这是一个提升自尊的办法，对吧？
Yes, let's do it.
是的，我们来吧。
I love Ted's face when he hears that Robin and Derek broke up.
我太喜欢泰德听到罗宾和德里克分手时的表情了。
Oh my God.
哦，天哪。
The Christmas morning, I'm trying to hide the Christmas morning.
圣诞节早晨，我正试图掩饰圣诞节早晨的喜悦。
Look, I've said right.
看，我说得对吧。
It's really fun as an actor to play two things at one.
作为演员，同时表现出两种情绪真的非常有趣。
It's fun to play the thing and then cover it, or cover it not that well, because of course he has to be like, oh, like a good friend, but the twinkle in his eye is like, yes, you know?
表现出那种情绪然后又去掩饰，或者掩饰得不那么好，这很有趣，因为他当然得表现得像个好朋友一样，但他的眼里闪烁着光芒，仿佛在说“太好了”，你知道吗？
It is an A plus reaction shot.
这是一个顶级的反应镜头。
It is a full on A plus reaction shot.
这绝对是一个不折不扣的顶级反应镜头。
I turned, I was watching with Rebecca and my wife and I said, that is a great, what Josh just did there.
我转过头去，当时我和我妻子丽贝卡一起看，我说：“乔什刚才那个处理真是绝了。”
That little, I was gonna single that moment out too, it was great.
那个小细节，我本来也想单独提出来的，太棒了。
Good job, Josh.
干得好，乔什。
Well, it's also good work there.
嗯，那里的处理也很棒。
It's also nice that you and Sue, you know, included that.
而且你和苏能把这个剪进去也很棒，你知道的。
Like it's important, like, to clock.
就像，捕捉到这一点很重要。
This is his receipt.
这是他的“证据”。
Let's say that.
我们这么说吧。
Let's talk about that for a second.
我们来谈谈这个。
Sue, our editor, who won, I believe three Emmys for how I met your mother, was one of her superpowers as an editor is that she just knew your guys' energy so well.
苏，我们的剪辑师，据我所知她曾因《老爸老妈浪漫史》赢得过三座艾美奖，作为一名剪辑师，她的超能力之一就是她对你们的能量有着极其深刻的理解。
She knew the cast.
她很了解演员阵容。
She really watched everything.
她真的看了每一段素材。
She mentally lobbed things.
她心里总盘算着各种镜头。
And she, so when her first first assembly cuts come in before we started honing it more.
所以，当在我们开始精剪之前的首版初剪交上来时。
So much good stuff was in there.
里面有太多精彩的内容了。
She really attuned, she's a musician.
她真的很有共鸣，她是个音乐家。
Sue, before she was an editor was a exceptional violinist in orchestra.
苏在成为剪辑师之前，是乐队里极其优秀的圆号手。
Or violist, yeah.
或者中提琴手，对。
Violist.
中提琴手。
And she, God, now I'm up in my head about which one it was.
天哪，现在我脑子里在纠结到底是哪个了。
Sue, I forgive me, forgive us all if you got this wrong.
苏，请原谅我，如果我们记错了，请大家原谅。
But she was, she had a music to her and she attuned to what you guys were doing so acutely.
但她身上有一种音乐感，她对你们的表演有着极其敏锐的感知。
So we, she would not waste that reaction.
所以我们，她绝不会浪费那个反应镜头。
I bet that was in her first assembly.
我敢打赌那就在她的首版初剪里。
She wouldn't sound like that.
她才不会剪掉那个。
You can make a case that Sue Federman knew the show better than anyone.
你完全可以说苏·费德曼（Sue Federman）比任何人都更了解这部剧。
Yeah.
对。
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我的意思吗？
She saw the 35-minute cut and she helped whittle it down to the 22.
她看的是35分钟的初剪版，并帮它精简到了22分钟。
Oh, longer sometimes.
哦，有时候还要更长。
So she saw every take.
所以她看过了每一个镜头。
Right?
对吧？
Yep.
是的。
I mean, she really got, and I think she, it was funny.
我的意思是，她真的抓住了精髓，而且我觉得，很有意思。
I remember when Sue would come to set, she would pop in every once in a while, and she would always, you know, she clearly loved this gig.
我记得苏每次来片场时，她都会时不时地露面，她总是，你知道的，她显然很热爱这份工作。
Like, this was a job she really enjoyed.
就像，这是一份她真正享受的工作。
And you could, you know, she always made us feel so good because she would say, I'm just having the best time, just having the best time at you guys, you know?
而且你可以，你知道的，她总能让我们感觉非常好，因为她会说：“我在这里过得太开心了，看着你们演戏我简直开心极了，你知道吗？”
And that was such a nice feeling because before you saw the Final Cut, you were like, oh, the person who's got their eyes on this first is really likes this, you know?
这种感觉真的太棒了，因为在看到最终剪辑之前，你会想：“哦，第一个看这些素材的人真的很喜欢它，你知道吗？”
She loved you guys and loved the show and like really got it.
她爱你们，爱这部剧，而且真的懂它。
And what a superpower to have that on the roster, right?
拥有这样一项超能力真是太棒了，对吧？
I mean, like, at every, we had the right person at every job on this show, which doesn't always happen.
我的意思是，这部剧里每个岗位我们都安排了最合适的人，这可不常见。
And yeah, what a lucky thing.
没错，真是太幸运了。
So those little moments, they don't get lost.
所以那些小细节，都不会被忽视。
Those little moments can see it.
那些小细节都能看出来。
When did Barney say, how way, way, way?
巴尼是什么时候说的“how way, way, way”？
What was that?
那是什么？
I wrote that one.
那句是我写的。
How way, way, way.
How way, way, way。
Alec, do you remember?
亚历克，你还记得吗？
We all watched this one day to go, less than 24 hours ago.
我们不到24小时前才刚一起看。
I'm blanking on that one thinking I bet people listening.
我想不起来了，心想听众们肯定在想……
No, this is the word is the first really the worst podcast of all time.
不，这绝对是有史以来最烂的播客。
It's not remembering what they watched 18 hours ago.
连18小时前看的内容都记不住。
Not just watch, but guys wrote it rewrote it.
不仅看过，伙计们还写过、改过。
Look, it's about the fallibility of memory.
听着，这说明记忆是不可靠的。
This show is about the fallibility.
这节目讲的就是这种不可靠性。
But it made me laugh.
但它确实逗笑了我。
It made me laugh.
它让我笑了。
How way way way.
How way way way。
Oh my God, I'm blanking.
天哪，我脑子一片空白。
Yeah, this is embarrassing.
好吧，这太尴尬了。
What maybe next time when you do notes, you can draw pictures right down time, like so What was it?
也许下次你做笔记的时候，可以画画或者记下时间？那到底是什么？
Is it Stewart who says you called our seven-year-old flower girl a whore or is that?
是斯图尔特说的“你管我们七岁的花童叫妓女”吗，还是别的？
Yes, yes, that's a secret line.
对，对，那是句暗中吐槽的台词。
So I want to shout out Stuart and Claudia Virginia Williams, Matt Boren, who They were so good.
所以我要感谢斯图尔特、克劳迪娅、弗吉尼亚·威廉姆斯、马特·博伦，他们演得太棒了。
A bunch of times over the years, right?
这些年来他们来过好多次，对吧？
Yeah, they came back a bunch of times, but I will say I don't want to cut you off, Josh.
对，他们回来过好多次，但我得说——我不是想打断你，乔斯。
If there's no go ahead Here's my observation.
如果你不介意的话，请说。这是我的观察。
Rebecca said this is rewatching it.
丽贝卡在重看时说过这个。
First of all, I want to say I love them and I love this episode and I love the hour that is this sort of two-parter.
首先，我想说我爱他们，我爱这一集，我爱这个上下两集构成的整整一小时。
It reminded me a lot about the pilot and Purple Giraffe when you rewatch those.
重看这些时，它让我想起了试播集和《紫色长颈鹿》。
It really is an hour.
它真的有一小时长。
It really is like one episode, the wedding and drum roll.
它真的就像是一集，婚礼和鼓点。
I'm having such a hard time not talking about drum roll already in this podcast because it feels of a piece.
在这期播客里我极力克制自己不去提前聊“鼓点”，因为我觉得它们是一个整体。
But Stuart and Claudia, It's very funny how in this episode, they just seem like they're the best friends of this group that you've never heard about until now.
但斯图尔特和克劳迪娅，很有意思的是，在这集中，他们看起来就像是这个圈子里你之前从没听说过、但其实是最好朋友的人。
And then you go a long way, never hearing about them again.
然后往后很长一段时间，你也再没听到过他们。
And when the wedding, the moment where the wedding falls apart, they've broken up as a couple.
当婚礼破裂、那一刻婚礼泡汤时，他们作为情侣也分手了。
Who does Claudia call?
克劳迪娅给谁打电话了？
She calls Lily.
她打给了莉莉。
Lily is not in her vital party.
莉莉甚至不是她的伴娘团成员。
Lily's not her maid of honor.
莉莉不是她的首席伴娘。
She's like, who's the one person I can talk about this?
她就像是在说，我能跟谁倾诉这件事？
Lily!
莉莉！
And it's just, it's very funny how much emphasis but I was like, Stuart and Claudia.
很有意思的是，我们赋予了那么多戏份，但我当时就在想，斯图尔特和克劳迪娅……
I was just, we really built that up.
我只是觉得，我们真的把这层关系建立起来了。
We really explained how they all knew each other.
我们真地解释了他们是怎么认识彼此的。
We just sort of like created this condition.
我们只是营造了这样一种设定：
They're all really close.
他们其实都非常亲密。
That's my one note on the episode.
这就是我对这一集的唯一看法。
My other note on the episode is, there's a moment in the episode where Lily has to be, is like, I'll go run out of the bar and comfort Claudia.
我对这集的另一个笔记是，剧里有一个时刻，莉莉必须去，就像是，我去酒吧外面安慰克劳迪娅。
You guys go talk some sense in a Stuart, or Marshall says, let's go talk sense in a Stuart.
你们去跟斯图尔特讲点道理，或者马修说，我们去跟斯图尔特讲点道理。
And the guys get to Stuart hours before Lily gets right downstairs to the bar.
结果在莉莉下楼到酒吧之前，这几个家伙早就到斯图尔特那儿了。
Rebecca was like, why is, why is there such a lag for Lily getting down the bar?
丽贝卡就问，为什么，为什么莉莉下酒吧会有这么大一截延迟？
And she's like, what happened there?
然后她就问，到底发生了什么？
And I was like, I don't know.
我说我也不知道。
I guess maybe she's taking a giant dump or something.
我猜她可能去拉了坨大的什么的。
That was my best.
那就是我的最佳猜测了。
I don't know.
我也不知道。
She was trying to keep because Lily was always being first season.
她当时在努力保持，因为莉莉第一季一直都是这样。
It takes Lily a really long time to, if Barney has plenty of time to try to get, to get, you know, work his moves on Claudia.
莉莉花了很长时间，如果巴尼有充足的时间去试图，去，你知道的，对克劳迪娅施展他的把戏。
And we really, if we had it in the script or the cut, we definitely didn't keep it in the air episode that aired.
而我们，如果剧本或剪辑里有这一段，我们绝对没有把它留在最终播出的剧集里。
Was there, did we ever talk about an obstacle of why Lillie didn't make it down there faster?
当时有，我们有讨论过莉莉为什么没能更快赶到那里的阻碍吗？
I can't remember.
我记不清了。
You know, speaking of the back of the script, friend groups, I have three very good friends, two of whom are married, but they're, they're just like my nearest and dearest, these people.
你知道的，说到剧本后面提到的朋友圈，我有三个非常好的朋友，其中两个已经结婚了，但他们，这些人就是我最亲密、最珍贵的人。
And we call ourselves the Cirque, right?
我们管自己叫“圈子”（The Cirque），对吧？
Like we're the circle, the four of us we play together, like we're, and people who get close to us are like, can I be in the Cirque?
就像我们是一个圈子，我们四个经常一起玩，而且那些走近我们的人会问，我能加入这个圈子吗？
We were like, oh, no, never, but we have a name for the people on the outside of the circle.
我们会说，哦，不，绝对不行，但我们给圈子外面的人起了个名字。
We call it the riff for the periphery.
我们叫它“边缘区”（the riff）或边缘地带。
Like you're on the, you're kind of, the riff.
就像你在，你有点算是在边缘区。
We say, what do you think, you can be in the riff, you know?
我们会说，你觉得呢，你能进入边缘区吗，你知道的？
So Stuart and Claudia were in the riff, but they would never be in the surf.
所以斯图尔特和克劳迪娅在边缘区，但他们永远进不了核心圈。
They were never gonna be in the surf.
他们永远不可能进入核心圈。
Yeah, they're in the riff, but yeah, they're not.
对，他们在边缘区，但对，他们不在里面。
It's just so funny that that's the person that like Claudia It's like, I've got to talk to Lily right now.
真搞笑，那个人竟然是克劳迪娅，就像是，我得立刻跟莉莉谈谈。
And there was something funny about that when we were watching it.
我们在看的时候，觉得这一幕挺搞笑的。
But they're so, they're both so perfectly cast because Virginia had a way of being kind of like a bridezilla but not in a way that was like odious.
但他们俩的选角简直完美，因为弗吉尼亚有一种方式，有点像个准新娘狂（brideszilla），但又不会让人觉得讨厌。
It was more like, no, she has a point, like you can't do this.
更像是，不，她说得有道理，你不能这么做。
That is fucking stuff up in here a little bit, right?
这确实把这里搞得有点一团糟，对吧？
You do not fuck with a bride.
你绝对不能惹新娘。
That is definitely fucking stuff up there.
那确实把事情搞得一团糟。
I also watch this now 20 years.
我现在看这个也已经是20年了。
I haven't seen this in 20 years.
我有20年没看过了。
You've gotten married since then.
从那以后你结婚了。
I've gotten married at a wedding.
我结过婚，办过婚礼。
Like I understand like if someone calls you two days before the wedding and they're like, can I bring a date?
就像我能理解，如果有人在婚礼前两天打电话给你，问“我能带个女伴/男伴吗？”
It's like, are you insane?
那感觉就像，你疯了吗？
Like this thing is designed with an inch of its life.
这东西可是精确筹备到每一分钟的啊。
I also thought it was funny that in 2005, like a wedding costing $400,000 is a really expensive wedding.
我还觉得好笑的是，在2005年，一场价值40万美元的婚礼真的是一场非常昂贵的婚礼。
Like it's expensive now.
现在办也很贵。
But like, that's a really expensive wedding.
但那个时候，那绝对是一场超级昂贵的婚礼。
That is a really expensive wedding.
那真的超级贵。
I know, we didn't, I don't know if we lived up to that in what we portrayed.
我知道，我们没有，我不知道我们在表现时有没有达到那种程度。
We see like a couple of little tables.
我们只看到几张小桌子。
It looks like a Hilton ballroom.
看起来就像希尔顿的宴会厅。
It doesn't look like, I think they got ripped off for that 400K for sure.
看起来不像，我敢肯定他们为了那40万刀被坑了。
Yeah, but Matt Boren is so, like he has the face of a like silent film comedian.
对，但马特·博伦太绝了，他长着一张无声电影喜剧演员的脸。
Oh yes, he's really funny.
哦对，他真的超级搞笑。
Like just an ability to just like be long suffering, You know, but not in a way where you feel like we got to go save him just in a way.
就有一种能够默默忍受一切的气质，你知道的，但又不会让你觉得我们得去拯救他，只是那种。
Like he's probably the only person who could just handle this, this energy.
他可能是在场唯一能hold住这种能量的人。
But he's kind of cocky in a way.
但他某种程度上有点自大。
He's kind of like, I could get someone hotter than Claudia and your reaction.
他有点像是在说，我能找到比克劳迪娅更辣的货，然后是你的反应。
Another great 10 moment is when he starts laughing way too fast and way too hard at that.
另一个精彩的满分时刻是，他开始对那件事笑得太快、太夸张。
And that's the kind of like pull back from it.
然后那是一种抽身而退的感觉。
Like, well, that's crazy.
就像是，好吧，这太疯狂了。
You shouldn't break up with your glottie.
你不该和你的克劳蒂分手。
That was a great moment.
那真是个精彩的时刻。
Yeah, the scene where where Marshall and where they go to stage the intervention is very good.
对，马歇尔去排练干预的那场戏非常棒。
I love that whole sequence.
我喜欢整个这段剧情。
There's so many funny moments in that and Marshall ending up saying you should you should break up with her and then saying the sort of great reason why like what the stakes are of getting married.
里面有太多搞笑的时刻，马歇尔最后说你应该和她分手，然后说出了结婚究竟意味着什么这样绝妙的理由。
I thought that was really I love Jason played that I love and I love Ted's Dude, like, I stole that shout out to my Kentin College roommate, Matt Olens, I stole that from him.
我觉得真的——我很喜欢杰森的演绎，而且我喜欢泰德的“老兄”——比如，我偷了这一招，向我在凯尼恩学院的室友马特·奥伦斯致敬，我是从他那儿偷学的。
He would do that all day.
他整天都这么干。
Dude, like, why are you saying that?
老兄，听着，你为什么这么说？
So I kind of took that from him.
所以我算是从他那里学来的。
You know, it was a dated moment too, if I may say so.
你知道，如果我这么说的话，这也算是个有年代感的梗了。
I think they're listening to great things about being single.
我想他们当时在细数单身的好处。
I know exactly what you're going to say.
我完全知道你要说什么。
Having single when he's like, having porn.
说单身的时候，他好像说的是，拥有色情片。
No, he said owning porn.
不，他说的是拥有色情片收藏。
Oh, yeah.
哦，对。
Sorry.
抱歉。
It's owning porn.
是拥有色情片。
And I was like, how quaint, how quaint, how quaint is it?
当时我就想，多古色古香，多复古啊！
You could only pour in one day.
你以前只能拥有色情片。
Where people owned their little, a little hand-picked curated up one stash.
那时候人们拥有他们自己的一小堆、精心挑选的色情片藏品。
Yeah.
对。
And that is the internet and modern life has gotten rid of that incredibly charming thing where guys have a bag of VHS tapes or something, or DVDs and- And you know what?
现在的互联网和现代生活已经消除了那种极其迷人的情景，就是以前有些家伙会带着一袋录像带之类的东西，或者DVD，然后——而且你知道吗？
Sometimes there was so much the circuits got jammed.
有时候藏品太多，线路都塞车了。
The circuits got jammed?
线路塞车了？
I was like, this is this episode, the circuits got jammed.
我当时就想，这一集里的线路塞车了。
This is us calling back that in the limo, they say the circuits got jammed a hundred times about cell phone calls and it makes it sound like we don't know how cell phones work.
这就是我们在呼应前面在加长轿车里，大家关于手机通话说了上百次“线路塞车”的梗，这听起来简直像我们根本不懂手机是怎么运作的。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
But I thought that was this week's of like owning porn.
不过我觉得这就是本周关于“拥有色情片”的梗。
Owning porn, yeah.
拥有色情片，对。
There's not a lot, it's shocking though, how few references date the show.
不过说实话，带有时代局限性的梗其实非常少，这挺让人惊讶的。
Like there's a couple that I think are actually quite charming.
我觉得有几个梗其实相当迷人。
They jump out when they do.
它们一出现就会跳出来吸引眼球。
They jump out and it's good.
它们跳出来的时候效果很好。
You know what I loved?
你知道我最喜欢什么吗？
I loved the fast forwarding sequence of the argument.
我喜欢那段快进吵架的桥段。
Wasn't that with Stuart and Claudia were breaking up?
不就是斯图尔特和克劳迪娅分手的那段吗？
Yeah, I love that.
对，我超喜欢那个。
We had to write a whole big, long argument for them.
我们得为他们写一大段长长的争吵。
Those were separate script pages that they sort of had to do.
那是他们不得不演的独立的剧本页。
And we said, it's not to be perfect on this, but they needed something that would take that long.
我们说，台词不需要一字不差，但他们需要一段能持续那么久的内容。
We're literally fast forwarding through what they're really saying.
我们字面意思上是在快进他们真正说的话。
That would have been great too.
那本来也会很棒。
I should sometimes go back to the scripts before we do these podcasts clearly, because I've not done my homework.
显然，在做这些播客之前，我有时候真该回去看看剧本，因为我根本没做功课。
It would be very cool if I had that and could just read what they're really saying.
如果我有那个剧本并能直接读出他们当时到底在说什么，那就太酷了。
But I don't, but they had a whole script.
但我没有，不过他们确实有一个完整的剧本。
but it was also cool.
但这也很酷。
It's a great storytelling thing because when you have like an argument that ends in a breakup, those are hours long, you know?
这是一个很棒的讲故事技巧，因为当你们爆发一场以分手告终的争吵时，那可是持续好几个小时的，你知道吗？
Hours and hours.
长达数小时。
And you literally, you remember three sentences from them.
而你实际上只记得其中的三句话。
You remember like the wounding lines or the ones that you're like, oh, we're not coming back from this.
你只记得那些戳痛你的话，或者那种让你觉得“哦，我们再也回不去了”的话。
Like this is really not.
就像这真的无法挽回了。
Yeah, we have crossed the Rubicon.
对，我们已经无可挽回了。
There's no putting this on that again.
再也没有回旋的余地了。
I love the moment where you stop and she just goes, end your mother.
我最喜欢你停下来然后她直接说“还有你妈”的那一刻。
I mean, you start fast-forwarding and that was my favorite moment of that.
我是说，你开始快进，那是我最喜欢的时刻。
They played that so great.
他们演得太棒了。
I wonder how long that went on for in real life.
我在想现实生活中那场吵架到底持续了多久。
I'm gonna say it was hours.
我猜得有几个小时吧。
Yeah.
对。
And then she goes and finally her best friend in the world.
然后她走开了，最后去找了她全世界最好的朋友。
It was also fun the way Virginia played Claudia was so, like, I mean, you know, when I think it's like Barney, like when you see it from the outside, you're like, why would these people be friends with it?
弗吉尼亚扮演克劳迪娅的方式也很有趣，就是那种——我是说，你知道的，就像巴尼一样，当你从局外人角度看时，你会想，为什么这些人会跟他做朋友？
But when you have that much history and you know them from the inside, you know.
但当你拥有那么深的历史渊源，从内部了解他们时，你就懂了。
But I liked how every time he had to call her, it was, he was justifiably scared, you know, like, yeah.
但我喜欢的是，每次他不得不给她打电话时，他都理所当然地感到害怕，你知道吧，对。
She was in a scary state for sure, but again, but she played it with a humanity.
她当时确实处于一种可怕的状态，但话说回来，她演出了人性的一面。
I liked it.
我很喜欢。
But again, the actresses have so much credit, Virginia.
不过还是要给女演员们很高的赞誉，尤其是弗吉尼亚。
Having now gotten married and understanding the stakes involved in a wedding, the how much planning goes into a wedding, and for just like someone on the riff to call and be like, hey, cool, if I bring a date, It's like, it's maddening, you know?
现在我自己结了婚，也明白了婚礼背后的利害关系，明白了筹备婚礼需要多少规划，而如果只是某个泛泛之交打来电话说：“嘿，酷，我带个女伴行吗？”这简直令人抓狂，你知道吗？
Oh yeah.
哦，是的。
So I'm kind of like, I'm emotionally with Ted, but logistically, I'm like, yeah, Claudia had every right to scream at him.
所以我有点——在情感上我站在泰德这边，但在现实统筹上，我觉得，没错，克劳迪娅完全有权力对大吼大叫。
Like there's no.
简直无话可说。
Claudia is so justified.
克劳迪娅太有理了。
Ted is wrong, Ted is in the wrong for most of this episode.
泰德是错的，在这集的绝大部分时间里泰德都做错了。
And she comes across crazy, but she has a point, which is what makes it good.
她表现得像个疯子，但她确实占理，这正是这部剧精彩的地方。
And Stewart is so great.
而且斯图尔特太棒了。
He just so haplessly walks into this, the drama he doesn't care about who's coming to the wedding and she really does.
他稀里糊涂地卷入其中，他根本不在乎谁要来婚礼，而她却在乎得要命。
and yeah, it's a great payoff when Robin doesn't even show up.
而且说真的，罗宾最后甚至都没出现，这个反转太棒了。
And I love how Virginia played that moment too, where she's relaxed in that moment.
我也很喜欢弗吉尼亚演那个时刻的方式，她在那个时刻放松了下来。
They're married, they're at the party.
他们结婚了，在派对上。
She's had a couple drinks.
她喝了几杯酒。
And she's like able to laugh about it the way that when you look, it's true, right?
她能够笑着看待这一切，就像你回首往事时一样，确实如此，对吧？
You look back in your wedding and you go, ah, right, it was just, essentially it's just a party, right?
当你回看自己的婚礼时，你会想，啊，没错，它其实——本质上它不过是个派对，对吧？
It's like once you've done it, you sort of like changes immediately.
就像一旦你办完了，你的心态马上就变了。
My friend is getting married this summer in Paris.
我的朋友今年夏天要在巴黎结婚。
And he asked for my kind of hard earned wisdom around weddings.
他向我讨教一些关于婚礼的“血泪经验”。
And I said, weddings are the dress rehearsal is the performance.
我说，婚礼的彩排根本不是真正的演出。
Like you do not really get to rehearse, like the rehearsal, like that's not a rehearsal.
就像你根本无法真正排练一样，那个所谓的彩排根本算不上排练。
Like so much goes on that is, you know, there's going to be the things in the speeches that are, that kind of wound you a little bit, you know, like my friend, a friend of mine told me he at his wedding that I was at, there was a table in the back that was some really good friends and they were just talking so loud.
会有太多事情发生，你知道的，致辞里总会有一些话稍微刺伤你一下，你知道的，就像我一个朋友告诉我，在他办婚礼时我在场，后面有一桌是几个很好的朋友，他们说话声音实在太大了。
And he was so upset by it, but then he was told later the speaker that was by their table was kind of blown out and it was outside so they couldn't hear anything.
他为此非常心烦，但后来别人告诉他，靠近他们那桌的音响有点坏了，而且又是室外的，所以他们什么也听不见。
So they were like kind of detached from the whole thing and I just tried to say to him like, it's gonna be chaos, a lot is gonna go wrong, but the wrongness is part of the rightness.
所以他们就好像跟整个婚礼状况脱节了一样，我当时就试图对他说：婚礼就是一团混乱，很多事情都会出错，但这种“出错”其实是“对的”一部分。
Like you just have to bless the whole thing.
你只能接受并祝福这一切。
A wedding is chaos, and it's almost like marriage, like you just bless it all because it's all, it's never gonna, again, like with Ted, it's never gonna go according to your specifications, but it's gonna unfold the way it's gonna unfold and you gotta be okay with that.
婚礼就是一团乱麻，这几乎就像婚姻一样，你只能对这一切送上祝福，因为事情永远——就像泰德经历的那样，它永远不会完全按照你的规格说明书来发展，但它会顺其自然地展开，你必须接受这一点。
Yeah, yeah, and yeah, it's funny.
对，对，而且这很有趣。
The whole thing, I mean, this whole episode is yet another like exploration of plans and meeting reality, right, from all ends.
整件事——我是说，这一整集其实又是一次对“计划”与“现实碰撞”的探讨，对吧，从各个方面来看都是如此。
And the idea that Ted essentially sets off these dominoes that lead to the couple breaking up, because he's trying to will this plan into being.
泰德试图通过自己的意志力让这个计划成真，结果却引发了一系列多米诺骨牌效应，导致这对情侣分手。
It's yet again, Ted's kind of hubris, right?
这再次体现了泰德那种盲目的自负，对吧？
If we're talking like basic Greek mythology story structure, like he flies too close to the sun by promising Ram in the slot.
如果我们用希腊神话的基本故事结构来形容，就像他答应了带罗宾去婚礼，结果飞得太高，离太阳太近。
And he is sorely punished.
然后他受到了严厉的惩罚。
And he really brings other people down with him when he comes crashing down.
而且当他重重跌落时，真的把其他人也一起拉下了水。
And you so understand you are rooting for Ted.
你会非常理解并支持泰德。
You know he's wrong.
你知道他是错的。
If you're the couple getting married, he's wrong.
如果你是那对要结婚的新人，他就是错的。
But you're so rooting for Ted.
但你就是忍不住支持泰德。
And you believe right when you first watched this episode, maybe you do think he checked that box, right?
而且当你第一次看这一集时，你真的会以为他勾选了那个选项，对吧？
We know he didn't because we know how the episode ends, but when you're first watching it, it's pretty convincing that he does, right?
我们知道他没有，因为我们知道这一集是怎么结束的，但当你第一次看的时候，你会觉得他真的勾了，挺有说服力的对吧？
The episode opens with him.
这一集一开场就是他。
It seems you almost feel like you saw him check the box.
你甚至会觉得好像亲眼看见他勾了那个选项。
Of course, we don't see which box he checks conveniently, but you feel like you see it and you work off that premise the whole time.
当然，我们很方便地没有看到他到底勾了哪个，但你会觉得你看到了，然后整集都基于这个前提往下看。
And then it was, I'm reminded of it was a real reveal that he didn't, and Barney is basically, I love another great Neil moment in that episode.
然后，这让我想起，他其实没勾是一个挺大的反转，而巴尼基本上——我太喜欢尼尔在这集里的另一个精彩表现了。
You know, so funny, his little Barney voice when he does a little Barney in the back of Ted's head.
你知道，太搞笑了，他模仿泰德脑海深处那个小巴尼的声音。
And I love that he's done this so many times and Marshall and Ted know exactly what it is.
而且我喜欢他这种恶作剧已经做过很多次了，马修和泰德一眼就能认出来。
I love the shared history.
我喜欢这种共同的过往。
But it's Barney's right, Barney's right.
但巴尼是对的，巴尼说得对。
Ted, some part of yourself deep down does not actually think you're ready for all the shit you're claiming you're ready for.
泰德，你内心深处的某个部分其实并不认为自己已经准备好去承担你口口声声说准备好的那些烂摊子。
And he's right.
他是对的。
It's also nice that even though Ted almost breaks up this marriage and ruins a $400,000 wedding, he's not a villain.
同时也很棒的是，尽管泰德差点毁了这场婚礼，拆散了一对新人，还浪费了一场价值40万美元的婚礼，但他并不是个恶人。
Like, that's really good writing, because it's not, you know, it's not like I'm scheming or, you know, Ted's scheming or doing something devious.
这真的是很棒的编剧手法，因为这不像是我在处心积虑，或者说泰德在密谋什么、搞什么阴谋诡计。
He's actually just trying to do the right thing.
他其实只是想做正确的事。
He's trying to do the right thing by Robin.
他只是想对罗宾做正确的事。
He wants everyone to have a good time at this wedding.
他希望每个人在这场婚礼上都能过得开心。
And I like that it's not a morality play.
我喜欢这不是一出道德说教剧。
It's like we screw things up, like the road to hell is paved with good intentions, like that's what it is, you know?
这就好像我们把事情搞砸了，通往地狱的道路往往由良好的意愿铺就，就是那种感觉，你知道吗？
Yeah, yeah, I really like that.
对，对，我真的很喜欢这一点。
It's complicated.
这很复杂。
No one's a purely the villain.
没有人纯粹是个恶人。
It is a really well written episode.
这真是一集写得极好的剧集。
Shout out to the writer, Courtney Kang, who wrote this one, who's been on the show with us to talk about an earlier episode.
向编剧考特尼·康（Courtney Kang）致敬，她写了这一集，她之前也来过我们的节目聊过前面的一集。
She'll be back for sure.
她肯定还会再来的。
Great, yeah, it's a great one.
太棒了，对，这集真的很棒。
And it's funny, it's the first, because drumroll please, in some ways, I think gets talked about more by the fans and maybe by ourselves too.
而且很有意思，这是第一集，因为请敲响鼓点，某种程度上，我觉得粉丝们甚至包括我们自己，谈论这一集的频率更高。
Like, because that's, we meet Ashley Williams.
因为在这集中，我们遇到了维多利亚。
There's so many very memorable things in that.
里面有太多令人难忘的东西了。
This episode's so important.
这一集太重要了。
It really is an hour long story.
它真的就像是一个长达一小时的故事。
Well, there's no drum roll without this episode.
如果没有这一集，也就没有后来的鼓点。
Like this tees it up perfectly.
这一集把一切都完美地铺垫好了。
Yeah, this is the drum roll, T-drum roll if it, as it were.
对，这就是那个鼓点，可以说是“鼓点前奏”吧。
And it's like, it, and it's really urgent.
而且它给人的感觉非常紧迫。
It feels like the stakes are incredibly high.
你会觉得赌注太高了。
I love when, I love when the stakes aren't bullshit.
我喜欢这种不是瞎胡闹的高风险。
It's like, for a minute in this episode, that wedding's off.
就像在这集的某一刻，那场婚礼眼看就要泡汤了。
I love it.
我太喜欢了。
It's like, it's really like stressful to watch in a good way, because you're like, there's really, and you really are rooting, you know, we're 12 episodes in and rooting for Ted and Robin or what's gonna happen with these two.
看的时候真的会让人感到紧张，但这种紧张是好的，因为你会觉得，而且我们已经看了12集了，你真的会为泰德和罗宾加油，想知道这两个人最后会怎么样。
And this is it really ramping back up.
而这一集让这种情绪再次急剧升温。
And the idea that Robin doesn't come, and Hetera's that moment of saying, it's just not easy.
罗宾没有来，而泰德迎来了那个感悟时刻，意识到事情没那么简单。
The universe isn't actually putting this into place for me and Robin.
命运其实并没有在我和罗宾之间刻意安排这一切。
Barney was right.
巴尼是对的。
I'm not ready for any of this.
我根本还没准备好面对这些。
And then the twist being that he ends up meeting this other super intense love interest, a huge part of his life-love story.
而转折是，他最终遇到了另一个强烈吸引他的爱慕对象，这是他人生和爱情故事中非常重要的一部分。
He meets Ashley Williams in that moment at the end of the episode, which one of my favorite music usages of the show, that soul meets body by death cab when you're pushing it on Ashley across the wedding, the $400,000 crappy hotel ballroom, it seems to be in.
他在这一集结尾的那个瞬间遇到了维多利亚，这也是我最喜欢的剧集音乐运用之一，当你在婚礼上把她推向那个价值40万美元、极其简陋的酒店宴会厅时，背景音乐响起了Death Cab for Cutie的《Soul Meets Body》。
Cash bar.
现金酒吧。
But I love that moment.
但我太喜欢那个时刻了。
And it's just interesting, because there's a lot of twists and turns there at the end.
而且这很有趣，因为结尾有非常多的反转和曲折。
I like that ramp where you actually does meet a very serious love interest in that moment.
我喜欢那个节奏的转换，就在他觉得一切无望的瞬间，他真的遇到了一位极其认真的追求对象。
He seems to be giving up upon it.
他当时似乎已经打算放弃了。
And if Robin hadn't gotten called to the station None of that would have happened.
如果罗宾没有临时被叫回电视台，这一切都不会发生。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you.
而这位老友，让我爱上了你。
New York City.
纽约市。
And now commercials.
现在是广告时间。
End of commercials?
广告结束？
Back to show.
回到节目。
I also think there's something about the age, that kind of tender age of like 27, where it feels like the weddings are starting in earnest.
我还觉得，关于27岁这个年纪，那种充满试探的微妙年龄，婚礼好像开始真正密集地出现了。
You know what I mean, especially in like New York, people get married a little later, like, there's something about that time where are you, do you have a plus one or don't you?
你知道我的意思吗，尤其是在纽约这种地方，大家结婚稍微晚一点，在这个阶段，你有没有带女伴（或男伴），这是一个问题。
Like, it's, it is, it is an existential issue.
这就好像是一个、一个关乎存在主义的问题。
You know, like, do I, do I keep myself available in a wedding?
你知道的，比如，我在婚礼上要不要保持单身状态？
Because people meet at weddings is one of the places where people meet and really, and it's such a romance is in the air and it's, it's hopeful and optimistic.
因为人们在婚礼上相遇，婚礼是人们相遇并真正擦出火花的地方之一，空气中弥漫着浪漫的气息，充满了希望和乐观。
And I think that, you know, that time, there's like a decade in your life where you're just going to a lot of of weddings.
我觉得在那个人生阶段，你的人生中会有大概十年时间，一直在参加各种婚礼。
And, and you know, when you go to them alone, it's, it's just a little trick.
而且你知道，当你独自一人去参加时，感觉其实挺微妙的。
I mean, I, some people prefer going to them alone and other people would rather have someone on their arm and, but they're, but they're provocative, right?
我是说，有些人喜欢独自去，而另一些人宁愿身边带个伴儿，但它们、但它们确实很有挑逗性，对吧？
Like they're, they're a little bit like, am I, is this ever going to happen to me or form it?
就好像它们在撩拨你的心弦，比如：这种事会不会发生在我身上？还是说就这样了？
You know, it's stir shit up for sure.
你知道，这绝对会把事情搅得天翻地覆。
And I think that's why people get a little too drunk at weddings, like say the wrong thing at weddings, like it's a, yep, they're provocative times.
我想这也是为什么人们在婚礼上总是喝得有点太多，比如在婚礼上说错话，所以说，没错，这些都是容易让人情绪激荡的时刻。
There's big feelings.
会有强烈的情感涌现。
This is what I say to my children.
这就是我对我的孩子们说的。
There's big, you're having big feelings.
你会经历强烈的情感。
There's big feelings at weddings, right?
婚礼上总会有强烈的情感涌现，对吧？
They're just, the stakes are really high.
就是这样， stakes（赌注/风险）真的很高。
I'm proud of this episode, it's two-parter in a way, because it's again, like with, it's the same thing as with a holiday episode.
我为这一集感到骄傲，它在某种程度上可以说是上下集，因为这就像是那种节日特辑。
Don't do a holiday episode unless you have a really good idea, a really good take on a holiday episode or else just don't do the holiday.
除非你有一个真正绝妙的点子、对节日有一个非常独特的切入点，否则千万别拍节日特辑，不然就干脆别拍。
Doing a wedding episode, doing a comedic episode comedic movie about a wedding, you're very aware of the 7,000 years of wedding-related material that has preceded your little attempt to do something, set at a wedding.
拍一集婚礼题材的电视剧，拍一部关于婚礼的喜剧电影，你其实很清楚，在你试图以婚礼为背景创作之前，已经有长达7000年之久的婚礼相关题材作品存在了。
And I like this dilemma so much, but I don't feel like I've seen this specific dilemma of like the plus one idea and the sort of symposium on, did I check this box and what's gonna happen?
但我太喜欢这个两难困境了，我觉得我以前没见过这种特定的两难局面——比如带女伴（男伴）的概念，以及关于“我到底有没有勾选这个选项，接下来会发生什么”的一场小型研讨会。
And then I really like the ending sort of has this two or three twists all at once.
然后我真的很喜欢结尾同时抛出的两三个反转。
He didn't check the box.
他没有勾选那个选项。
Maybe he's saying he should let go of Robin.
也许他是在说，他应该放手罗宾了。
He doesn't want to be, he wants to be single.
他不想被束缚，他想保持单身。
He looks across the room and literally sees an expert and he's going to fall in love with in that moment.
他抬头望向房间对面，一眼就看到了一个行家，并将在那一刻无可救药地坠入爱河。
I love that in the last like 30 seconds of this episode, a lot happens.
我喜欢这一集最后大约30秒里发生的这一切。
Yeah.
对。
There's that thing.
有这么个说法。
It's a little bit of a new age cliche, but it's like something like the universe only gives you three answers to your prayers or requests.
这有点像新时代的心灵鸡汤，但大意是：宇宙对你的祈祷或请求只会给出三种回答。
One is yes, another one is not yet.
一个是“可以”，另一个是“还不是时候”。
And the third one is I have something better in mind.
第三个是“我为你准备了更好的”。
you, right?
对吧？
And Ted gets a, at least in this, you know, two-parter, he gets a, I have something better in mind for you right now, you know?
而泰德，至少在这个、你知道的上下集里，他得到的就是：“我现在为你准备了更好的”这种回答，对吧？
He gets both not yet and I have something better in mind.
他既得到了“还没准备好”，而我又想到了更好的主意。
He does, I love that.
他是这样的，我太喜欢了。
It's kind of like, it's a, it is a really fresh take on weddings and, you know, you could almost see the themes and stuff of this being expanded into a feature, like it would be a great kind of feature film about a wedding, right?
这有点像，这是一个对婚礼非常新鲜的视角，你知道的，你几乎可以看到这些主题被扩展成一部长片，就像一部关于婚礼的伟大的故事片一样，对吧？
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Well, sometimes the answer of if you're afraid, how do we do a good wedding episode?
嗯，有时候当我们感到害怕时，答案就是：我们该如何拍出一集精彩的婚礼呢？
Or how do you do a good New Year's Eve episode?
或者你该如何拍出一集精彩的跨年夜呢？
In both that episode and this one, which are back-to-back in the running order of season one, you never see the New Year's Eve party, and you basically don't see the wedding, right?
在那一集和这一集里——它们在第一季的播放顺序中是紧密相连的——你永远看不到跨年夜派对，而且基本上你也看不到婚礼，对吧？
There's no wedding.
根本没有婚礼。
You skip over the wedding, you're like, we don't become a cliche comedy take on weddings because you don't even see it.
你直接跳过了婚礼，心想，我们才不会落入那种俗套的喜剧婚礼模式，因为你连看都看不到。
It's all about the run up to the wedding, and then the next episode basically jumps way into the past the wedding.
重点全在婚礼前的筹备，然后下一集基本上就直接跳到了婚礼之后很久。
It's the Rosenkrantz and Guildenstern, right?
这就是《罗森克兰茨与吉尔登斯特恩》的套路，对吧？
It is.
确实是。
It's way different.
非常不一样。
Yeah, you follow the side characters.
对，你关注的是配角。
It's also, I don't know if you, we might have discussed this, but did you read the Mark Harris' Mike Nichols biography?
这也是，我不知道你，我们可能讨论过这个，但你读过马克·哈里斯写的迈克·尼科尔斯传记吗？
No, I don't know, not read it yet.
没有，我不知道，还没读过。
I keep hearing how good it is.
我一直听到别人说这书有多好。
If you're like, in showbiz, it's like, I think, essential reading.
如果你在娱乐圈的话，这简直可以说是必读之书。
It's just really, it's like juicy, but also edifying somehow, and he was such a fascinating character.
它真的非常有意思，但不知为何又很有教益，而且他是一个如此迷人的人物。
but one of his truisms about romantic comedies, he said, if you want to make a classic romantic comedy, they can't get together at the end.
但他关于浪漫喜剧的一句名言是，他说，如果你想拍一部经典的浪漫喜剧，他们在结局时就不能在一起。
The graduate is kind of like this really discordant, weird ending.
《毕业生》就有点像这种非常不和谐、诡异的结局。
It's not like a big celebration.
它不像是一场盛大的庆祝。
It's like, what have we done?
它更像是，我们到底做了什么？
That kind of look as they go on that bus towards an uncertain future.
当他们坐上那辆驶向不确定未来的巴士时，就是那种眼神。
And I think that, You know, how I make your mother like both fulfills, it gives you everything you want, and it's constantly pulling your rug out from under you at the same time.
我认为，你知道，就像《老爸老妈浪漫史》一样，它既满足了你的愿望，把你想看的东西都给了你，但同时又不断地在釜底抽薪。
Yeah.
对。
And when Harry Metzali, there's that feeling at the end of when Harry Metzali, but it's still a journey, right?
还有当《当哈利遇到莎莉》时，片尾有一种那种感觉，但它依然是一段旅程，对吧？
It just ends with the two of them, and she's sort of like going on her long run at the end, as they're just sitting there, doing their little couple, sort of like talk to the camera thing.
它以两人的画面结束，她在片尾开始长跑，而他们就坐在那里，像小两口一样对着镜头聊着天。
And it's true.
确实如此。
It's like, we all love a happy ending and a warm wrapped up ending, but it's true, they're really all timers.
就像我们都喜欢大团圆结局和那种温馨圆满的结尾，但确实，那些真正名垂青史的作品。
There's always something a little, there's a little, the edges aren't always sanded down at the end, because that's a great observation of my medicals.
总有一些若即若离的东西，有些棱角在最后并没有被磨平，因为这是迈克·尼科尔斯的一个伟大观察。
And if you're, if you're an acute observer of life, very rarely are things symmetrical, perfect.
如果你是一个敏锐的生活观察者，事情很少是完全对称、完美的。
Like, you kind of have to bless the, what's the, that Japanese thing, Wabi Sabi?
所以，你有点必须赞美那个，那个叫什么来着，日本的那个词叫“侘寂”吗？
Do you know what that is?
你知道那是什么吗？
like Japanese artists will put an intentional flaw in their piece and it's like a wink from the artist that says, I'm an artist, I'm an imperfect being and also like, I acknowledge that there is nothing perfect.
就像日本艺术家会在他们的作品中故意留下一个瑕疵，这就像是艺术家的一记眨眼，在说：我是一个艺术家，我是一个不完美的人，同时我也承认，世上没有绝对完美的事物。
So we should just dispense with that fiction right away.
所以我们应该马上抛弃这种虚构。
Yes, that's great.
是的，这太棒了。
Yeah, that's great.
对，这太棒了。
Yeah.
对。
I think it's the same ideas as doing an episode about a wedding and not showing a wedding or doing episode by New Year's Eve.
我认为这和拍一集关于婚礼却不展示婚礼，或者拍一集跨年夜是一个道理。
It's like, so much of life happens not at the thing you think it's about.
这就好像，生活中大部分的事情并不是发生在你以为的那件大事上。
It happens around the thing.
它发生在事情的周边。
And before the thing and after the thing, it's almost a testament to there's no endings.
在事情发生之前和发生之后，这几乎证明了世上本无终点。
There's one, death is the one big ending.
唯一的终点，死亡才是那个盛大的终点。
Well, it's also the thing of like, we're, and I think part of the challenge of life is to not be the main character all the time.
嗯，这也是那种感觉，我们，而且我认为生活中的挑战之一，就是不要无时无刻都当主角。
That's why having children is like healthy for the soul and sometimes hard on the ego, because you really have to dethrone yourself.
这就是为什么生孩子对灵魂有益，但有时又对自我是一种打击，因为你真的必须把自己从主角的王座上请下来。
But when you're at a wedding, you are the main character of your story of the night, but you're not the main character of that evening because that's the bride and groom, right?
但当你去参加婚礼时，你可能是你当晚故事的主角，但你并不是那个晚会的主角，因为主角是新郎新娘，对吧？
So you're like 10 rows back, and you're having, you know, maybe an argument with your wife or girlfriend, whatever, like, but that's your experience of the wedding is from that perspective.
所以你大概坐在倒数第十排，你可能正在和妻子或女朋友争吵，随便什么都好，但你对婚礼的体验就是从那个角度出发的。
That's the story of your wedding.
那就是你关于这场婚礼的故事。
And the bride and groom are kind of like, fogging off in the distance.
而新郎新娘就像是，在远处渐渐模糊。
Totally, it's totally Rosingrad's ago that's starting to wait and figure it out.
完全是，完全是罗辛格勒式的发展，开始等待并弄清楚状况。
It's like that's what it's like to go to a what?
就像那是去参加什么的感觉？
You're not the main characters.
你们不是主角。
You are off, but there, you can have all this drama going on off on your little table at table 10.
你们在旁边，但在那里，你们在10号桌的小桌子旁可以有各种抓马。
There's a whole other drama happening.
还有另一整套抓马在上演。
Yeah, what was, I just had one other question, to Marshall.
对，还有一个，我刚才还有一个问题，想问马歇尔。
Interpreting your notes.
解读你的笔记。
When did Ted say to Marshall, do you think she's into me?
泰德是什么时候对马歇尔说，你觉得她对我有意思吗？
Like, it was kind of like a- I love that moment.
就像，那感觉有点像——我太喜欢那个时刻了。
It was like in the middle of a heated thing and then- Yeah.
就像在激烈的争论中，然后——对。
And then he drops it all like, do you think, you know, He's so ready to drop plans to drop.
然后他突然把话全抛出来，比如，你觉得，你知道，他随时准备抛开计划。
Like he helped his entire energy changes when the possibility that.
就像当这种可能性出现时，他的整个人都变了。
Yeah, and you know what?
对，你知道吗？
It's a callback to the limo.
这呼应了加长轿车的梗。
Remember it's a callback to the limo when Ted and his date are up and up through the sunroof of the limo.
记得吗，这呼应了加长轿车的那一幕，当时泰德和他的约会对象从轿车天窗探出头来。
It's like, really?
就像，真的吗？
Do you, do you, do you, do you, do you do me?
你，你，你，你，你对我有意思吗？
It's very, it's like two of those in two episodes.
这太像了，两集里出现了两次这样的桥段。
And yeah, very funny the way you play that.
而且是的，你演得非常有趣。
That was another good one, Josh.
那是另一个精彩之处，乔什。
See, we're gonna compliment you.
看，我们要夸夸你。
I'm gonna give some notes on the writing when I'm gonna give you compliments.
我一会儿要对剧本提出一些看法，现在我要先夸夸你。
The other writing note I have is like, for this whole two-parter, no one should ever answer the phone.
我关于剧本的另一个看法是，对于这整整上下集，谁都不应该接电话。
There's always like, ah, we've solved the problem.
总是有，啊，我们刚解决问题。
Ring, ring, and then the phone, and it's like, Robin gets called to go do the newscast.
铃铃铃，然后电话响了，就像，罗宾被叫去播新闻一样。
I said, it was watching me in the back, I said, no one should ever answer the phone on TV.
我当时在后面看的时候就说，在电视里谁都不应该接电话。
The phone's always just don't answer the fucking phone.
电话总是——别接他妈的电话。
But those are the Deus Ex Machina, those are the universe.
但那是机械降神，那些是命运的安排。
That's how the universe like disrupts everyone's plan.
那是命运如何打乱每个人的计划。
It's the universe calling, it's the universe calling, for sure.
是命运在召唤，是命运在召唤，肯定的。
I wanna say one thing just about the overall writing instructor of this is that if you think of this episode, sort of as a twist, it's a bit of a twist episode, right, because we really feel like this is about the back and forth of Ted and Robin, and then you give us this wonderful twist.
关于这集的整体编剧结构，我想说的一点是，如果你把这集看作是一个反转，它有点像反转剧集，对吧，因为我们真的觉得这是关于泰德和罗宾的分分合合，然后你们给我们来了这样一个精彩的反转。
And I think a lot about how successful twist movies, the best ones are ones that work not quite without the twist, but that the second time around, it's not just about the twist.
我经常思考为什么有些成功反转的电影，最棒的那些往往不是完全没有反转也能成立，而是重刷的时候，不单单只是为了反转。
It's still great storytelling until then.
在此之前它依然是极佳的叙事。
And I feel like that's what you have here.
我觉得这就是你们在这里做到的。
You have this great Ted and Robin confusion, wedding episode, oh, and there's this twist.
你们有泰德和罗宾之间这种精彩的纠葛、婚礼插曲，哦，然后还有这个反转。
But then as from everything you guys are talking about, it's completely part of the fabric of the episode, the idea that this is leading somewhere for him.
但正如你们大家所讨论的，这完全融入了这一集的骨肉之中，这个情节是在为他后续的发展做铺垫。
A lot of perfect things had to happen or not happen to get to, I can see this girl across the room and pursue it.
必须发生很多完美的事情，或者不发生某些事情，才能让他走到“我能看到房间那头的这个女孩并去追求她”这一步。
And it just really worked both ways for me.
对我来说，这两种方式都处理得非常完美。
Yeah.
对。
That's nice to hear.
听到这话真高兴。
I really liked that on second watching, too, and realizing that this spins you in a whole new part of the season.
我也特别喜欢二刷时的感觉，意识到这把剧集带入了这一季一个全新的篇章。
That's great.
太棒了。
You think we're going back to Ted and Robin, and maybe people watching you be like, oh, that's pretty soon to go back, right?
你们觉得我们在重回泰德和罗宾的故事线，也许观众看着会觉得，哦，这么快就回去，对吧？
I thought we put that to bed, and now they're all friends.
我还以为我们已经把这事放下了，现在他们都是朋友了。
It's already coming back in the dead middle of the season.
结果在剧集的正中间它又卷土重来。
It was complete mislead.
这是一个彻底的障眼法。
We were actually not gonna come back to them until the end of season one.
我们实际上直到第一季结束都不会再回到他们的故事线。
And I like that this spins it out into something completely unforeseen.
我喜欢这种安排，它把剧情引向了完全意想不到的方向。
And yeah, it's the universe calling.
而且是的，这是命运的召唤。
Alright, let's, uh, Josh, we have a very special, uh, portion of our show.
好了，我们，呃，乔伊，我们节目有一个非常特别的，呃，环节。
Would you like to introduce it?
你想介绍一下吗？
Oh, sure.
哦，好啊。
Yeah, this is very exciting.
对，这非常令人兴奋。
This is, uh, a section we like to call questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother and also happens to be married to Josh.
这是，呃，一个我们喜欢称之为“来自一位临床心理学家的提问与观察”的板块，她从来没看过《老爸老妈浪漫史》，而且刚好是乔什的妻子。
So I was most taken by that moment when Ted came to the conclusion based on Marshall's advice that love shouldn't be that hard, should be simple and easy.
所以泰德根据马歇尔的建议得出结论，认为爱情不应该那么难，应该简单轻松，那个时刻最触动我。
And I'm so often working with patients around this concept, what should it feel like when you found the person you're meant to be with?
我和患者共事时，也经常探讨这个概念：当你找到命中注定要在一起的那个人时，感觉应该是什么样的？
What parts should feel easy?
哪些部分应该让人觉得轻松？
And when is it okay and actually normal for it to feel quite hard?
什么时候觉得挺难的其实也是正常的、可以接受的？
Because, you know, in truth, long-term love does indeed take work.
因为，你知道，事实上，长期的爱确实需要经营。
And how do you know when it's too hard?
又该如何判断什么时候是“太难了”呢？
So these are very big questions, but I am wondering where you stand here, you know, more specifically, what is easy and what's the kind of hard that just is the price of admission for a long-term relationship?
所以这些都是很大的问题，但我很好奇你的看法，更具体地说，什么是轻松的，而哪种困难又是长期恋爱必不可少的代价？
That's a good one.
这问题问得好。
I found myself thinking about it too, Jernana.
我也在思考这个问题，杰娜娜（Jernana）。
When you're watching, when Marshall gives that speech, I hadn't watched that speech in a long time and it felt very young to me.
当你看着、当马歇尔发表那段演讲时，我很久没看那段演讲了，觉得当时的自己非常年轻。
Marshall is the older, wiser guy in that moment because he's engaged and he's been with Lilly since he's 18 years old from freshman year of of college.
那一刻的马歇尔是个更成熟、更有智慧的人，因为他订婚了，而且从18岁大一就开始和莉莉在一起了。
And yet, looking back at it now, it's like, that is kind of a young take in a way, because it's not easy, right?
然而，现在回过头来看，这多少有点年轻人的视角，因为事情并不轻松，对吧？
It's not.
确实不轻松。
It's like you have to work at it.
这就好像你必须为之付出努力。
It's nothing is always effortless.
没有什么是永远毫不费力的。
I think he was talking about, there has to be some spirit of effortlessness.
我想他当时说的是，必须有一种毫不费力的精神。
There has to be some effortlessness to the decision to be with that person, right?
对于和那个人在一起的这个决定，必须得有一种不费吹灰之力般的笃定，对吧？
That's how I took it.
我是这么理解的。
It should be like, well, I have to breathe oxygen.
这应该就像，好吧，我需要呼吸氧气。
That's not negotiable.
这是不容协商的。
It should kind of feel that right?
感觉应该差不多是这样，对吧？
Love should feel that way.
爱情就该是这种感觉。
It should feel worth, I guess it should be an effort, this decision, and then beyond that, you know, there's going to be hard stuff.
我觉得，这个决定本身应该是值得的、毫不费力的，而在那之后，你知道，会有艰难的事情。
But the decision part should feel like it's natural to you.
但做出决定的那部分应该让你觉得顺理成章。
And I think that's how I viewed the speech this time.
我想这就是我这次看待那段演讲的方式。
How did you feel that, Josh?
乔什，你当时是怎么觉得的？
How did you interpret that?
你是怎么解读的？
Yeah, I think that's right.
对，我觉得没错。
I mean, I think, especially in first season, Marshall and Lily do have a, they're, I mean, because they're, they're, especially in this first season, they're more, they are the parents, they're like Ted's parents, you know, they are, that really is a role that they play.
我是说，我觉得，特别是在第一季里，马歇尔和莉莉确实有种……我的意思是，因为他们，特别是在第一季里，他们更像是父母，就像泰德的父母一样，你知道，这确实是他们扮演的角色。
And even Lily, this is a drum roll line, but she says, to Robin, like, happiness shouldn't be this hard.
甚至莉莉——这里有个高潮台词——她对罗宾说，幸福不应该这么难。
Doesn't she say something like that?
她是不是说了类似的话？
She does.
她确实说了。
Yeah.
对。
Which is both great.
这番话既很棒。
And also, like a little bit condescending and a little, like not entirely true.
同时又有点居高临下，还有点，并非完全真实。
Yeah.
对。
I think some people struggle in their career very mightily, some people struggle in relationships.
我觉得有些人事业上举步维艰，有些人则在感情中苦苦挣扎。
But I don't think that anything we do as humans, I don't think that anyone can inoculate themselves against struggle and hardship.
但我不认为人类做的任何事、我不认为任何人能让自己对挣扎和苦难免疫。
I think it's coming for all of us in various forms.
我觉得各种形式的苦难终究会降临到我们所有人头上。
And I think when it comes to relationships, a friend of mine who's older than me, but very wise about relationships, he said, you know, the thing that makes us fall and love is this feeling of similarity.
而谈到亲密关系时，我的一位年纪比我大、但在感情上非常有智慧的朋友说过，你知道，让我们坠入爱河的东西，是这种相似感。
Like, oh my God, we love the same bands and the same movies and we have the same taste and aesthetic and, you know, and we both love to talk about our feeling, like all these things that go check, check, check, check, check.
就像，天哪，我们喜欢同样的乐队、同样的电影，我们有相同的品味和审美，而且，你知道，我们都喜欢谈论感受，所有这些都完美契合，打钩、打钩、打钩、打钩。
Oh, don't we line up?
哦，我们难道不是天作之合吗？
And that's, it's almost like nature's way to get you bonded, right?
这几乎就像是大自然让你把彼此绑在一起的方式，对吧？
And then after you've been with a person for a while, these differences start announcing themselves.
然后当你和一个人相处了一段时间后，这些差异就开始显现出来了。
And then you have to navigate The the difference, you know, I don't think Jordy, I don't want to mind me saying this but like a central thing in our relationship is like She is a Google calendar planner in a way that would make your head spin like she'll go Hey, do you want to do so-and-so next Thursday at three and I'll go Okay, and I'll look down on my phone and I already I have a Google calendar invite.
接着你必须去处理这些差异，你知道，乔迪，我介意你这么说吗——比如我们关系中的一个核心问题是：她是一个谷歌日历规划狂魔，程度会让你头晕目眩。比如她会说：“嘿，你下周四三点想去干吗干吗吗？”然后我会说：“好吧。”接着我低头看手机，发现自己已经收到一个谷歌日历邀请了。
It's there down, it's just she leaned it into my phone.
它就在那儿，她直接同步到我手机里了。
And I have a thing where I don't know how I'm going to feel at Thursday on Thursday at three because I'm not thinking about Thursday at three, I'm thinking about today.
而我有个毛病，我不知道自己周四三点会是什么心情，因为我没在想周四三点的事，我在想今天的事。
That's future Josh's problem.
那是“未来乔什”的麻烦。
It's future Josh's problem, it's not my problem.
那是“未来乔什”的麻烦，不是我的麻烦。
And I think that, you know, I don't know if this is so gendered because I think there are men who are incredibly regimented and planning and list making and all those things.
而且我认为，我不知道这是否带有性别色彩，因为我觉得有些男人也极具条理性、喜欢规划、列清单以及所有这些事情。
But I have had to yield and bend more towards, Like, I've really had to like get on top of the Google shared calendar, right?
但我不得不向现实妥协并做出更多调整，比如，我真的不得不开始使用共享的谷歌日历，对吧？
Like, like for the sake of my marriage, I've had to become much more of a planner.
为了我的婚姻，我不得不变得更有规划性。
And planning vacations is very hard because I'm like, I don't know how many of you, I don't know how I'll have a job then, you know, I'm talking about our marriage.
而且规划假期非常难，因为我想，我不知道你们有多少人……我不知道到那时候我还有没有工作呢（我是指我们的婚姻）。
I know.
我懂。
Did she walk in right as you began this page?
她是不是刚好在你开始说这段话的时候走进来了？
So everyone, it's been a real navigation.
所以各位，这真是一段不断磨合的过程。
And it's also like, you know, she's had to bend and yield in certain ways towards, and I've had to bend and yield.
而且这也是，你知道的，她在某些方面也必须做出妥协和调整，而我也必须妥协和调整。
but that's the kind of thing where, you know, that's like good struggle, like that's like good, you know, and it also I think part of the blessing and opportunity of a relationship is it dislodges you from your patterns or at least highlights them to be seen, which sometimes is you don't want them to be highlighted seem like, you know, but it ultimately makes you a more elastic kind of person, right?
但这就是那种，你知道的，好的挣扎，就像是那种好的，你知道的，而且我也认为亲密关系的祝福与机遇之一，就是它能打破你的固有模式，或者至少把它们暴露出来让你看见——虽然有时你并不希望它们被看见、感觉像是在被审视，但它最终会让你成为一个更有韧性的人，对吧？
And which I think is a net positive, right?
而我认为这是一个绝对的积极因素，对吧？
It's a net positive.
这是一个绝对的积极因素。
You have to evolve, right?
你必须进化，对吧？
You can't get with someone and it's all a yes and you need to be challenged a little bit or else you'll never grow.
你不能和一个人在一起，然后凡事都只有“好啊”，你必须受到一些挑战，否则你永远不会成长。
Even this episode, it's funny, the storyline, the little B, I wouldn't even call it a B, but a C or D story runner like is Lily and Marshall not agreeing on anything about this wedding.
甚至这一集，很有趣，这条主线剧情，这个B线剧情——我甚至不该叫它B线，应该算C线或D线剧情跑马灯——就是莉莉和马歇尔在这个婚礼的任何事情上都意见不合。
And again, to come back to the gender flip idea, Marshall wants this much sort of like, you know, Lily says, oh, you've been dreaming of, you know, Marshall's like, I'm dreaming about wedding ever since I was and she's like a little girl, you know what I mean?
再说一次，回到性别对调的想法上，马歇尔想要这种非常传统的、花里胡哨的婚礼，莉莉却说：“哦，你一直梦想着……”马歇尔就说：“我从小到大一直梦想着办婚礼……”而她就像个小女孩一样，你知道我的意思吗？
There's a little gender flip there.
这里有点性别对调。
Marshall wants this way more traditional sort of fruity wedding.
马歇尔比她更渴望这种非常传统、花哨的婚礼。
And she clearly wants something a little less traditional out in the woods.
而她明显想要一些不那么传统、在树林里办的婚礼。
And like, this whole episode's storyline is them not agreeing on shit.
而且整集的故事线就是他俩在各种破事上意见不合。
And yet he's still his overall feeling that he says to Stewart is it should be effortless.
然而他对他向斯图尔特表达的整体感受仍然是：这应该是不费吹灰之力的。
And I think he's talking about the decision to go through this thing called life with this other person, even as he's at the same time, not agreeing on any one thing with Stuart.
我想他说的应该是和另一个人一起走过这段名为人生的旅程这个决定本身，尽管与此同时他在任何一件事上都跟斯图尔特——我是说跟莉莉——意见不一致。
I mean, with Lilly, he's still able to say this to Stuart, and you see, when they finally got to the wedding, there's like this little moment where they agree on one thing about the wedding planning.
他仍然能对斯图尔特说出这样的话，而且你看，当他们最终走到婚礼现场时，有那么一个小瞬间，他们在婚礼筹备的一件事情上达成了一致。
But that's not, that's not Marshall and Lilly being in lockstep, you know?
但这并不意味着马歇尔和莉莉总是步调一致，你知道的？
Right, right.
对，对。
Also, though, I think in some ways, I don't think like in later seasons, like it doesn't It seemed like Lily Aldrin would want an outdoor way.
不过话说回来，我觉得在某些方面，我觉得在后来的剧集里，莉莉·奥尔德林看起来才不会想要什么户外婚礼呢。
I know, we met a little bit of a little bit of a little like hippie for her.
我知道，我们遇到的这个版本对她来说有点太……有点太嬉皮士了。
Like I don't know.
我是说，不知道。
A little hippie.
有点嬉皮士。
Yeah.
对。
Like I feel like Marshall would want like a Minnesota, like the high school football field in Minnesota or something.
我觉得马歇尔反而会想要那种明尼苏达风格的，比如明尼苏达的高中足球场之类的婚礼。
You could have flipped it there.
你当时是可以把他们对调一下的。
Yeah.
对。
You could have flipped it.
你可以对调一下的。
Yeah, it's true.
对，没错。
We're still finding the characters.
我们还在摸索这些角色。
The one thing we need for sure is that Lily's best friend is Claudia, that I'll stand by.
我们唯一可以确定的是，莉莉最好的朋友是克劳迪娅，这一点我坚信不疑。
Alec, I couldn't help but notice you're wearing a really nice shirt today.
亚历克，我忍不住注意到你今天穿了一件非常好看的衬衫。
Do you want to talk us through that?
你想跟我们聊聊这个吗？
Top bro.
顶流兄弟。
Yeah, top bro.
对，顶流兄弟。
Oh my God.
噢天哪。
Okay.
好吧。
And then we know what's going on Instagram now with this whole thing.
然后现在我们都知道Instagram上关于整件事的动态了。
This is this part of a new March here.
这是新品牌宣传的一部分吗？
This is our college style.
这就是我们的大学风。
How we made your how what is the show called?
我们是怎么制作你的……这个节目的名字叫什么来着？
How we made your mother?
《我们是怎么制作你的母亲》？
Yeah, that's what's called this shirt.
对，这件衬衫就是这么叫的。
You're the producer of it.
你是这个节目的制作人。
Yeah.
对。
You work on the show because I was a good show.
你参与了这个节目，因为这是个好节目。
Um, I don't have the, I should know this because I am the producer, but I believe by the time you're hearing this, we have already been to Wesleyan University and, and, and, and done a little live show there, which will be in our feed.
嗯，我没有……我本该知道这一点的，因为我是制作人，但我相信，当你们听到这段音频时，我们已经去过卫斯理大学，在那里做了一场小型现场秀，这会收录在我们的节目源中。
And we thought, okay, well, we're going to a college, like a college style shirt, uh, we've got another one that's just our logo, 10% of all the profits are going to, uh, how you make a difference are our, our campaign to support a congenital heart disease research.
我们当时想，好吧，我们要去一所大学，弄一件大学风格的衬衫；我们还有另一款只有我们标志的衬衫，所有利润的10%将用于“如何创造不同”（How You Make a Difference）项目——这是我们支持先天性心脏病研究的活动。
Very proud of that.
对此我们感到非常自豪。
And I'm just going to tell you this, I'm going to tell you that I'm going to, kids, I get to say that, kids, get to say the incredible story of how we met our friends at Amplifier who are partnering with us to get some legendary, how we made your mother merged you while raising money for congenital heart disease research.
我只想告诉你们，孩子们，我可以这么说，孩子们，我们要讲一个不可思议的故事：我们是如何结识 Amplifier 的伙伴们的，他们正与我们合作，推出一些传奇的《我们是怎么制作你的母亲》周边，同时为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金。
Amplifier is helping us to do something good by offering, premium fans, something great.
Amplifier 正在通过为忠实粉丝提供极棒的周边来帮助我们做一件好事。
So if you are a business with big orders to fulfill, Amplifier is there to help growing consumer brands and influencers create a unique experience for their customers during the fulfillment process.
因此，如果您是一家有大量订单需要履行的企业，Amplifier 可以帮助不断发展的消费品牌和网红在履行订单的过程中为客户打造独特的体验。
The link to their site is in our show notes and if you name drop how we made your mother, you'll get special pricing for your emerging brands program.
他们网站的链接就在我们的节目简介中，如果您提到《我们是怎么制作你的母亲》，您将为您的新兴品牌项目获得特殊定价。
If you want to get this merch, just go to howimajormother.com, click on store.
如果您想买这些周边，只需访问 howimajormother.com，然后点击商店。
You could also go to howyougetyourmerch.com and you'll go right to our Shopify location.
您也可以访问 howyougetyourmerch.com，直接跳转到我们的 Shopify 页面。
Alec, if we do any social media posts about the merch, which I assume we will, I think Hot Top Bro is a good.
亚历克，如果我们发布任何关于周边的社交媒体帖子——我猜我们会发布的——我觉得“Hot Top Bro”是个不错的名字。
Hot Top Bro.
Hot Top Bro。
It's fantastic.
太棒了。
Yeah.
对。
It's going up.
它快上线了。
It's going to be up.
它马上就会上线。
It's going to be up before people hear this because we record this now.
它会在大家听到这期节目之前上线，因为我们现在就在录制。
It comes out in four weeks, but there will have been just exactly that.
它会在四周后发布，但到那时情况确实就是这样。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
Awesome.
太厉害了。
Yes.
是的。
And the reason for cause really close to my heart, close to it, it's the doctor who is the expert and in condition my son has and also works just with the larger pediatric congenital heart population doing research to help kids like that.
之所以这样做，是因为这件事深深触动了我的心，非常贴近我的内心：那位医生是专家，不仅精通我儿子所患的疾病，还与更大的儿科先天性心脏病群体一起工作，进行研究以帮助像他这样的孩子。
So yeah, thank you guys.
所以，是的，谢谢你们。
Anyone anyone who buys this merch, you're supporting something really and truly amazing that's very, very close to my heart, my family starts to thank you.
任何购买这些周边的人，你们都在支持一件非常、真正了不起的事情，这深深触动了我和我家人的心，谢谢你们。
And you become a walking ambassador for the show, so we're super grateful for that.
而且你们成为了这个节目的行走的代言人，对此我们超级感激。
Now, as tradition dictates, I'm going to read a wonderful letter that we received.
现在，按照传统，我要宣读一封我们收到的美妙信件。
Please write us letters, submit voice notes, maybe we'll read your letter on the air or or hear your voice at the start of an episode, but just tell us what, how I met your mother means to you or any other wonderful, how I met your mother related things you want to share with us.
请给我们写信、提交语音留言，也许我们会在节目中读你的信，或者在节目开头播放你的声音，只要告诉我们《老爸老妈的浪漫史》对你意味着什么，或者任何你想与我们分享的、与《老爸老妈的浪漫史》相关的精彩事情。
Go to how we made your mother dot com contact.
访问 how we made your mother dot com 上的联系页面。
Is that right Alec and then everything should be pretty clear after that.
是这样吗，亚历克？之后一切应该就很清楚了。
Okay.
好的。
So this is a wonderful letter we received from Emily.
所以这是一封我们从艾米丽那里收到的美妙信件。
It says, December 2008, I was at the hospital delivery unit at the start of what was to be an almost 48 hour labor.
信上说：2008年12月，我在医院的产房里，经历了一场长达近48小时的分娩的开始。
My husband zipped out and returned with his laptop and season three of how I met your mother, which he'd quickly picked up at Best Buy.
我丈夫飞奔出去，带着他的笔记本电脑和《老爸老妈的浪漫史》第三季回来了，这是他在百思买（Best Buy）顺手买的。
We'd been watching together since in season one, I'd been a Buffy fan and follow it, Alison Hannigan.
从第一季开始我们就在一起看这部剧，我曾是《吸血鬼猎人巴菲》的粉丝，一直关注着艾莉森·汉妮根（Alyson Hannigan）。
I'm sure we had already seen all of season three, but I remember us sitting on the hospital bed together waiting and waiting, and at least for a little while, pleasantly distracted with these great characters we do so well.
我敢肯定我们当时已经看完了第三季的所有内容，但我记得我们俩并肩坐在病床上，等待着，等待着，至少有一小会儿，这些我们如此熟悉的伟大角色让我们得到了愉快的转移视线。
We'd also moved from New York a few years prior and reveled in the nostalgia for evenings with friends at our favorite bar, even while we looked toward our future.
几年前我们也从纽约搬了过来，虽然我们正朝着未来迈进，但我们仍对与朋友们在我们最喜欢的酒吧度过的那些夜晚充满怀念。
I started re-watching this series this past January for the first time and came upon the new podcast on a subreddit.
今年一月，我十多年来第一次重新观看这个系列，并在一个子版块（subreddit）上偶然发现了这个新播客。
Such perfect timing.
时机真是太完美了。
And imagine my delight as well to discover that I'd missed most of Season 8.
想象一下，当我发现自己错过了第八季的大部分内容时，我是多么高兴。
My second child was an infant then.
我的第二个孩子当时还是个婴儿。
It's also possible I did watch it, but just have no memory of it.
我也可能确实看过，但完全没有记忆了。
So it's like a whole lost season for me, rebound.
所以对我来说，这就像是整整失落的一季，失而复得。
Thank you for the show.
谢谢你们带来这个节目。
It has a ton of heart and its creativity knows no bounds.
它充满了人情味，其创造力永无止境。
I'm grateful to you all for putting this out in the world, even if I'm pretty sure it is behind my continued overuse of the word awesome.
我很感激你们把这个带到世界上，尽管我相当确定它是我不断过度使用“awesome（太棒了）”这个词的罪魁祸首。
You did good.
你们做得很好。
Be well.
保重。
Emily from Oberlin, Ohio.
来自俄亥俄州欧柏林的艾米丽。
Thanks, Emily.
谢谢你，艾米丽。
Thank you, Emily.
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
I love when people have like these core memories that have been formed around how I met your mother.
我喜欢人们围绕《老爸老妈的浪漫史》形成这些核心记忆。
Like we're our little show is part of the birth of her child and she remembers that.
就像我们的这个小节目成为了她孩子出生的一部分，而她一直记得。
And that's great.
这太棒了。
In a very meta way, not to do spoilers, there is an episode of how I met your mother about distracting a pregnant woman who is in painful labor with storytelling, right?
用一种非常元叙事的方式——剧透预警——《老爸老妈的浪漫史》里有一集，讲的是通过讲故事来分散正在经历痛苦分娩的孕妇的注意力，对吧？
There's an episode just spoilers, we are constantly trying to figure out whether we're doing spoilers of the show.
有一集……剧透一下，我们一直在试图弄清楚我们是否在剧透这部剧。
But way later in the series, there is an episode where that's the idea of the episode, and now we're hearing how much mother fulfilled that role for her.
但在剧集后来的发展中，有一集就是这个主题，现在我们听到母亲（指节目）是如何为她扮演了这样的角色。
So that's really cool.
所以这真的很酷。
I also think it's funny discovering like a lost treasure trove of how I met your mother episodes.
我也觉得发现一处《老爸老妈的浪漫史》剧集的失落宝藏很有趣。
But I'm not sure I might have seen this, but I had no memory of it.
但我不敢确定我是否看过这个，因为我对此毫无记忆。
Think about it.
想想看。
You didn't even know what your notes on this episode meant that you wrote last night, Josh.
乔什，你甚至都不知道你昨晚写下的关于这一集的笔记是什么意思。
Now imagine it's basically a year of your life like that.
现在想象一下，你生命中的整整一年都是这样的。
But it's funny because one thing that I ascribed to how I met your mother super fans is an intense memory of every episode.
但这很有趣，因为我一直认为《老爸老妈的浪漫史》超级粉丝的一个特征就是对每一集都有深刻的记忆。
So it's really funny that the kind of mom brain would eradicate this It's the whole season in your head.
所以这种“妈妈脑”竟然能把整整一季从你的脑海里抹去，真的很搞笑。
Yes, happens to dads too, to be fair.
是的，公平地说，爸爸们也会这样。
Yeah.
对。
Thank you, Emily.
谢谢你，艾米丽。
That's awesome.
这太棒了。
We're so honored to have been a part of your labor.
我们很荣幸能参与你的分娩。
It's a weird sentence, but we are.
这句话听起来有点怪，但我们的确如此。
I am guilty.
我有罪。
Please equip me.
请原谅我。
All sins are forgiven in New York City.
在纽约市，所有的罪过都可以被原谅。
How we made your mother is hosted an executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们是怎么制作你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）和克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev）制作，我们的联合制片人是道格·马蒂卡（Doug Matica）。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer AKA Gen Z Master is Emily Blumber.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves），我们的数字内容制作人兼 Z 世代大师是艾米丽·布伦伯（Emily Blumber）。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面艺术由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）创作。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这确实对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner, with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作的《NYC》，配乐由克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基（Andrew Majuski）提供。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪（Lola Kennedy）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
您也可以点击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是本节目重要的组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些周边吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
点击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Father's Society, also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的 Muse Letters，在 CraigThomasRider.com/novel 订购克雷格·托马斯的长篇小说处女作，您也可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死去的父亲协会》（Dead Father's Society）。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解有关“如何创造不同”（How You Make a Difference）的更多信息——这是本节目为筹集先天性心脏病研究资金而持续进行的活动——
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
请查看我们网站顶部的“Make a Difference”标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
本期节目得到了 Backyard Ventures 的大力支持。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞的。
A real question, it just hit me, am I in love with you?
一个真正的问题，我刚刚想到的，我是爱上了你？
Or just New York City?
还是仅仅爱上了纽约市？